welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka d'Arthur nishan
a ka death vader aka this is the last
time you'll have to sit through this
intro for a long time a promise the
Mandalorian finale is finally here and
it's time to break down everything that
you need to know about the ending of the
season throughout this video we'll be
discussing the new releases overall plot
the big death mind-blowing moments and
its many many Easter eggs so sit back
strap yourself in and get ready because
we're going Lightspeed - a long time ago
in a galaxy far far away there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to watch episode 8 yet and
don't want to know what happens then I
highly suggest that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into our breakdown of the
Mandalorian okay so episode 8 picks up
on the huge cliffhanger at the end of
episode 7 the speeder bikes a baby Yoda
and mondo Korra and grief gaga are in a
pretty impossible situation where
episode 8 differs slightly though is
that the introduction actually starts
off with a dark sense of humor we see
the two speeder bike troopers reference
that Imperial warlords like to kill
their own men and this is something that
we've seen throughout Star Wars history
most namely Darth Vader who had no
problem offing his own troops they
practice shooting at some scrap and miss
which is a nice callback to the old Star
Wars joke that stormtroopers can't aim
the troopers kind of bumbled back and
forth and it's a comedic moment until
they cross the line in hate baby Oda
you don't hit baby Yoda and here make
sure that they pay for it is IG 11 after
the death of Nick Nolte last week I'm
just calling him that because every time
I pronounce it queal or cool I get in
trouble in the comments anyway he's back
to avenge his master there were a lot of
theories last time that I ji 11 had
turned bad and cemented the Mandalorians
prejudice against droids showing that
you can't really reprogram them but the
bot is back to prove him wrong and we do
know now that he did not kill his master
I did theorize this last week as the
concept dog did show the speeder bikes
firing out cool I mean Nick Nolte so he
assume that it is these two that killed
him IG 11 takes them out with no effort
and it's an awesome rescue scene that I
loved watching but this is no time to
celebrate math Gideon is still at the
village with a squadron of storm
troopers and death troopers that are
ready to take the mando and coat down
death troopers were originally
introduced in rogue one and these elite
soldiers are the best of the best of the
best sir
they primarily work as bodyguards for
high-ranking Imperial officers and are
also masters of stealth as well as
hand-to-hand combat which they
demonstrate in this episode death
troopers are trained to be exceptional
and they specialized in heavy weapons
demolition and guerrilla warfare the
Moff is also described as being an ex is
be officer which stands for Imperial
Security Bureau this class of soldier
was sort of like an internal affairs for
the Empire that watch the ins and outs
of the day to day for dissenters so yeah
not the types of people that you want to
trifle with storm troopers begin setting
up an e webb heavy repeating blaster
that I'm so glad they said because I did
not know the name this raises the stakes
massively and the group try and escape
the situation aiming to get to the
sewers the sewer gray is very similar
looks wise to the one on the Death Star
that we saw in a new hope but they must
have reinforced them since then because
this one isn't opening with a couple of
blaster bolts unable to escape the moth
taunts the group revealing their pasts
and so on this is the first time we hear
the mandos name dropped in an episode
though Pedro Pascal did reveal and it
was denying in an interview after the
first episode it's never been said on
screen and it shows that the moth is
probably subscribed to this channel for
the breakdowns as you should too thank
you very much you also divulges that
chorus full name is Cora Cynthia Doon
and that she's from Alderaan which was
famously destroyed in a new hope by the
Death Star this adds a lot of motive for
why she joined the rebellion and
tattooed their symbol on her face we
learn that din jarring wasn't born on
Mandalore and then seymour is back story
in which separatists ravaged his home
Gideon also talks about the night of a
thousand tears which is directly tighted
endurance past we finally get the
entirety of the death of dins parents
and how he was able to escape the super
battle droid that discovered him hiding
we see separatist ships flying through
the village and during the Clone Wars
these were under the orders of Count
Dooku
Dinn was saved by a character that looks
extremely like Jango Fett uniform wise
from not only is Arial but also his
backpack however there are several other
troopers wearing the same thing and of
course Jango is dead by the time that
the clone was started so yeah this
definitely isn't him
according to Star Wars lore the Jedi
were fighting to free Mandalore during
the Clone Wars and during the siege
order 66 took place though whether we
will see this actually play out in the
show is completely unclear right now
later in the episode there is a
reference to the Mandalorians most
notably their leader Mandalore the great
who fought an army of sorcerers named
the Jedi then became so attached to
Mandalorians because they saved him he
was raised in the fighting Corps and
became the man that we know and love
Gideon would only know his true name if
he had access to information seized
during the purge and this he's clearly
been keeping tabs on the character
gideon makes a massive impact and the
dialogue is awesome here painting the
character out is one of the most
intimidating villains that we've seen
for a long time in Star Wars law he
gives them till nightfall to cooperate
though this doesn't go down too well
with most of the group Korra wants to
shoot her way out as she won't be
subjected to a mine fire which is a
callback to Dungeons & Dragons and also
stranger things it could also be a
reference at the bog ally from rogue one
and the mind flayer it could be a slang
term for it they realized that baby Oda
must be safe or they'd be dead and IG
eleven rides towards the village of
murdering many wells baby Oda giggles in
a very adorable moment yay can kill more
during this ride we also spotted shower
and they are laced throughout the
episode acting as scavengers that take
parts from the damaged items that appear
the action scene is incredible and
probably the high point of the season
with mono and Co taking down storm
troopers like Rambo in a Rambo movie
that's a terrible punchline there's even
a moment that reminded me of the 50 Cal
from those films and yet brilliant
brilliant scene unfortunately though
they're a bit difficult to hold off and
the death troopers storm Korra and
Gideon gets a huge shot on mondo that
reminded me of when you shoot an
exploding barrel in video games
nice work Gideon Gideon also commands a
flame trooper to burn their mouths and
the group retreat able to make it to the
sewers with the help of IG 11 mando is
badly wounded though and refusing to
take his
he decides to stay behind and buy them
some time this is the way it's a
massively tense scene and watching the
flame troopers slowly walk towards them
it's completely nail-biting
luckily baby otter is on deck and using
his force powers he kills the trooper
though this takes a lot out of him so
yeah no force healing this time
this ain't the rise of Skywalker Korra
grief and baby Oh to leave and I g11
watches over him and removes his helmet
Healing him so that he can recover it's
the first time that we've actually seen
petrol pascal in the show and it's a
real high point now I'm glad they held
off until now as he's not a living thing
IG 11 can technically see his face and
this is able to save him and it doesn't
take long before mando is leading the
way back to his guild he discovers a
pile of Mandalorian helmets though which
are obviously the result of the
Mandalorians being made almost extinct
which has been dropped in a lot of
episodes throughout the season the Amuro
reveals that after their uprising they
were pretty much all but wiped out some
have made off world but she's remained
behind in order to salvage their armor
she discusses the Jedi and how baby Yoda
seems to be able to wield the power of
them she also tells mano to reunite baby
order with its own kind in order for it
to be trained
neither character knows of the creatures
homeworld and this is in keeping with
Star Wars law in which we've never
actually learned the true name of the
species or where they come from this saw
upsets up season two in which they'll
likely go looking for a place for the
child they're attached meant in some
ways mirrors held in was found and then
taken under the wing of the Mandalorians
the rescue has clearly had an influence
on him and this is why he decided to do
the same for baby Yoda as he probably
saw a lot of himself in the character as
rules go baby owner is a foundling a man
doe is now his father maybe we should
start calling this Star Wars a solo dad
story I'd love that
anyway he's given a jet pack made a clan
of two and told to get ready for the
battle ahead it really gets you invested
in the finale of the episode and I loved
watching the crew prepping for the storm
that was coming they discover a bodge
operated by an r2 unit that seen better
days and begin making their way up the
stream to the lava pit the r2 has been
modified with arms and legs and it sails
them towards the lava flats and
fortunately a stormtrooper ambush is
waiting for them and there's no way to
stop the incoming storm trooper the
terrible terrible joke IG 11 decides to
sacrifice himself and it feels like the
most impactful droid death that we've
ever seen in Star Wars cover it's worked
out all of the odds and knows that this
is the only way I g11 has a safety
protocol in place that dictates that he
cannot be captured and will
self-destruct if ever it looks like he's
gonna be compromised this happens here
an ID 11 wipes out the squadron but
Gideon arrives in his tie making phone
almost North by Northwest kind of
standoff maybe that maybe that's a reach
but nevermind baby odor unable to do the
magic hand thing forces mando to jetpack
up and take the ship on head-to-head it
really feels like pure fanservice and
what a way to end the season making for
one of the most memorable standoffs that
we've seen in Star Wars for years mando
straps a detonator to the hull and this
sends it crashing to the ground Gideon
is finally defeated and mando has saved
the day
mando can expect to pay rise Korra
decides to say uh Navaro and we look
forward to a brighter future with the
Empire cleared out from the planet grief
office mando a future in which he can
come back to the guild with open arms
and pick up any job that he wants to but
mando decides that being a father is
more important and he goes off into the
galaxy with his clan of to nick nolte is
buried a hero and baby yoda begins
chewing the Mandalorian necklace mando
gives it to the lad and everything looks
chirpy as they leave the planet heading
off into parts unknown giving us a happy
ending or so we think we cut him off
Gideon's tie and seemed cutting his way
out of the craft with a black lightsaber
whilst on the surface this looks like a
cool little moment there's actually a
lot of subtext to it as this is the dark
saber which is a ceremonial weapon that
the leader of the Mandalorian planet
used to carry the dark saber was built
by the first ever Mandalorian to be
inducted into the Jedi Order and since
then it's been passed down from
generation to generation and the fact
that Gideon is carrying it shows that he
was instrumental in the fall of the
Mandalorians Gideon will likely have his
sights set on the pair now after his
crushing defeat and it's unlikely that
they will have a he
out there in the cold reaches of space
with the character constantly on their
back personally I think that they will
set out to find baby out his home planet
and this will finally be set in stone in
the Star Wars law we will also likely
get baby Yoda developing its training
and who knows next season you may even
be on his way to his teenage years a
Jedi and Mandalorian combo on to be
trifled with but Gideon even more so now
has his sights set on the character so
it's very unlikely that they'll have an
easy ride now obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on the Mandalorian Episode
eight as well as what your theories for
the future are make sure you leave them
in the comment section below and if you
enjoy this video then please force push
that like button make sure you check out
our full breakdown about thoughts on
Star Wars the rise of Skywalker which
would be linked at the end we go over
all of the pot holds things that we
liked and things that we didn't so yeah
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more you want to come chat
to me after the video then make sure you
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey or head over to my discord server
which should be linked in the
description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's free to join and we
have an awesome community so hopefully I
see over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of Joker which
is one of our favorite movies of the
last year and all you have to do to be
in with the chance of winning is like
the video like she subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on the
mandalorian in the comments section
below the winners gonna be chosen at
random on the 15th of January in the
cell be shipped out from the into ever
gets the prize it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]